here is is that a woman who sleeps with
a lot of men right that's that's because
because that's easy to do so it's like
it's easy for a woman to just sleep with
a lot of guys go outside and say does
anyone want to have sex with me you can
get it done if a dude does that they
look at him like he's nuts
you know what changed my like
perspective on this is i went to a
pickup artist boot camp once
this is the wildest thing i've ever seen
like these guys paid thousands of
dollars to learn how to get laid yeah
thousands of dollars and literally like
went through coaching like trying to
figure out how to build attraction with
a girl like all this stuff so and i'm
just like all i all i have to do is
exist so if you bring that back to what
you have a vagina you will get laid but
if we bring that back to what we were
talking about in terms of virginity when
we were younger in terms of like girls
weren't really thinking about it that
much and then assad is this victory
right isn't that what we're taught but
that's what's pushed onto us that men
losing their virginity and sleeping with
lots of women is like this you know like
high achievement so they pay lots of
money because if you get laid a lot then
you're seen as you know successful right
yeah i would say it is a high
achievement because historically most
men didn't even reproduce only 40 of men
reproduced historically where 80 of
women did and even up 8 000 years ago 17
women reproduced for every one man and
so it's it's like
that's an achievement most men don't
even get to reproduce and i know like
now you know you take away the
reproduction because we have birth
control but you don't get rid of biology
so are we reducing it to reproduction
then so a woman who that was the initial
reason for that we've definitely
developed as a society right past that
point where it's not just about
reproduction but i'm saying like you
can't get rid of the way people feel
in terms of like men are naturally
predispositioned to be repulsed by a
girl that sleeps around and so i'm just
like the same way you
typically women like men that are taller
than us and men don't come to us and say
oh you shouldn't like men taller than us
like no so i would say again that that
would like
there's some angry little men out there
evolving over time right biologically
evolving over time i'd say that there's
other attitudes that have also evolved
over time kind of and then probably
taking up more space now maybe haven't
got to the same point as that same
mindset but i do think we can get to a
point where that can shift right
especially because it's evolved it's a
mindset's evolved based on what we've
been taught we can be taught different
things and change that gradually but we
have to be open to that so i i agree
with you i do think it's evolved over
time yeah where like typically before as
i said like i would say men are more
forgiving with body count than they used
to be so i would agree with you that it
has evolved but is it better
like are the outcomes better i would
nowadays is that any space that kind of
promotes like i said acceptance and
understanding of
why we behave in certain ways and why we
drift towards certain things and and
understanding how it can harm because i
feel like that kind of mindset of like
um in terms of you know if you slept a
lot of people as like women as a man
you're successful is is essentially
harmful um because it places a lot of
that emphasis on on that um harmful
things
but the thing is it's true and i just
think like you you can live in delusion
and yeah it's true right now and i would
agree with that yes i would say that
that is if we talk about the general
that is kind of the general mindset at
the moment i would agree but does that
mean it's the best mindset right and and
who are you to determine what's the best
mindset yeah because i'm trying to
understand that you said it's harmful
harmful to who you like so so okay so in
terms of like situations like grape
right men who are like in cells right
who who don't maybe have that same
achievement right they they kind of
resort to quite violent means in order
to reach that same level success or or
they feel kind of like you know put out
because they don't get to be able to do
it and that's why insult culture kind of
develops because they think like a
certain group of men only gets all the
women because you know they're this high
level and then and then often they turn
violent right and it can be very
destructive you when you place all the
emphasis on that like macho not macho
which is probably not the right word to
stay there um that like hyper masculine
focus on on on sexuality and seeing it
as something to achieve right when we do
that and then men don't and then they
don't feel masculine anymore and they
feel emasculated by it and that can turn
very violent so it can be dangerous for
society and i'm not saying this is me
you know saying oh this is i'm saying
it's it's a point to consider it's a
thing to talk about when we're
considering what's best for you you're
actually somewhat correct it is
dangerous for society what like the more
um
like the when there's a large group of
men that aren't getting laid basically
that is dangerous versus you know what
happens when men don't get laid but it's
because the emphasis is on the fact that
you know and that's where we've put so
it becomes more aggressive
no males yeah
exactly
become more aggressive but i think
that's because of the emphasis that we
put on being late and essentially that
comes from biology survival reproduction
it's not an emphasis it's a biological
thing but it's it's we are taught that
we are taught that through biology that
is something that has evolved based on
what we've been taught and through a
need for survival right to reproduce to
be able to you know reproduce your blood
and lineage and that sort of thing it's
a survival base
you don't know what it is there are
other ways to release you don't have to
release just through sex
you're a woman i'm a man men need to
release their testosterone they need to
have testosterone hang on they need to
find a way in which they need to release
how do you release how do you release
but by shagging some shagging some birds
is that how you release is that is that
your release is that
sorry you just said you just said wait
yeah i hear you but what i'm saying to
you is
men are biologically wired
a certain way
are you a biologist
men are biologically wired a certain way
okay okay so
so what happens in society is that when
men are not getting
sexual
when men are not sexually um also what
i'm looking for gratification
yes that's the word when men are not
sexually gratified they get more
aggressive do they so
sorry when they are more sexually
gratified mm-hmm they're less violent is
that where you're violent
okay that is the biggest logical fallacy
i've ever heard in mind i would say that
[ __ ] it's not a logical fallacy it is
it's true i would i would i would say
thank you i'd have to agree all right
okay so so we've got three men saying
it's true so you explain why it's a
logical fallacy
so you're saying that if i don't get
laid i'm gonna hit someone i said you
explain why it's a logical fallacy well
you said you've never had trouble
talking to women so you probably
wouldn't know what that's like right
like
you said earlier in the show you've
never had trouble talking to women
you're good with the ladies yeah so you
guys should really ask justin about this
yeah you guys should really ask justin
about this he has a lot of study and
history and like knowledge on the go
well so i mean it's evolutionary
psychology but more so than that like i
mean if a man masturbates he can get it
really so you won't feel as aggressive
right but if i mean
i don't know if you guys ever heard of
nofap i'm a huge advocate for the no fat
movement and
uh like seven years into it right and i
i know if i don't have sex for like i
don't know a week or two i start feeling
extremely aggressive right and i think
it's very common for for men to feel
that way
because when you abstain from sex your
testosterone is increasing you need to
have that release
and if you don't believe me go try it go
stop drinking off stop having sex for
two weeks three weeks and see how you
feel
but would you not agree there's other
ways to release other than just sexual
you're a woman
masturbation
yeah no i realize that i'm talking to
men thank you but i i can enter into the
conversation
right and i'm saying are there not other
ways for you to release not just sex
through exercise right through physical
engagement and and healthy in in a
controlled environment right it's not
the same as bussing or not
fair enough thank you justin thank you
for being so like so justin you're so
honest you're like you're you're club
promoter
youtuber yep yes yes like your your work
outlet is
having conversations like this yeah and
busting a nut yeah yeah sure yeah sweet
so how how do you how do you manage your
aggression you say you're seven years
into this nofap how do you manage your
question when you feel it coming up
fair enough
as many of you know i was just banned on
tick-tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform
if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible